digamos digamos que tengo un subconjunto
de rn b b es un subconjunto de rn que de
hecho es
sube espacio
espacio
r
y les recuerdo brevemente qué significa
que desea un sub espacio pues significa
que si tengo un vector hay un vector b
que son miembros de el conjunto b
entonces a mars b el vector a más el
vector b también está
de esta propiedad a esta propiedad se le
conoce como cerradura
cerradura bajo adicción
así se llama esa propiedad de un modo
muy formal y también eso no es todo lo
que necesito también necesito que si si
tengo un escalar por el vector a que
pertenece a b entonces esto también
pertenezca ve a esto se le llama
cerradura
cerradura bajo
ésta está muy fea cerradura bajo
multiplicación multiplicación por
escalares
y finalmente también tengo el requisito
de que el vector 0 por 0 también está en
el conjunto de y quizás creen que este
requisito es algo vacuo o que está
además por esta condición pero realmente
no porque este requisito es precisamente
lo que me garantiza que b no es el
conjunto vacío así que es una condición
en verdad bastante útil pero bueno
últimamente hemos estado hablando de
transformaciones así que puedo
considerar t una transformación lineal
de rm en r m
entonces en el vídeo pasado habíamos
dicho que
dv
al aplicarle la transformación a cada
elemento del conjunto de esto ya lo
llamamos los llamábamos la imagen
la imagen
dv
bajo
les recuerdo que en el vídeo pasado
estábamos de hecho trabajando con
triángulos y teníamos tenemos un
triángulo teníamos una transformación d
r2 en r2
y en esa transformación lo que hacíamos
era que habíamos considerado un
triángulo triángulo así y vimos que la
transformación lo enviaba en un
triángulo que estaba algo inclinado
estaba como chueco este triángulo de
aquí se transformaba en este otro
triángulo bajo la transformación d
y entonces lo que hemos dicho era que
este triángulo el triángulo chueco
estoy acá arriba decíamos que eso
la imagen
de el triángulo original del triángulo
amarillo del término rectángulo bajo
bajo la transformación de nada más que
una observación solo es que en este caso
el triángulo no es un sub espacio
estábamos aplicándole la transformación
a un subconjunto de rn que era este
triángulo pero que no era un sub espacio
todos los espacios son subconjuntos pero
no todos los subconjuntos son sub
espacios hay que tener cuidado con eso
pero bueno la pregunta que yo quiero
contestar en este vídeo
la pregunta que quiero contestar es si
me fijo en la imagen de b que ve es un
sub espacio b es un sub espacio de rm
entonces la pregunta es su imagen
un sub espacio
espacio de donde pues por ejemplo en
este caso tomamos un triángulo y
obteníamos otro triángulo en r2 pero era
por que r2 era el co dominio así que en
este caso el condominio srm por lo tanto
la pregunta es la imagen debe bajo la
transformación t es un sub espacio de rm
esa es la pregunta que quiero contestar
en este vídeo
bien pues sí quiero checar si la imagen
de bajo t es un sub espacio de rm tengo
que sacar estas tres propiedades la
cerradura bajo adición la cerradura bajo
la multiplicación por escalares y que el
elemento cero que el vector cero
pertenezca a este subconjunto así que
bien qué elementos de la imagen de be me
puedo tomar pues simplemente me tomo
y de dos vectores en b
entonces la transformación aplicada al
vector a es un elemento de la imagen
debajo de la imagen debe bajo t
simplemente es aplicarle la
transformación t a todos los elementos
de b pero ciertamente es un elemento
debe así que esto está en la imagen de b
bajo t y también se debe está en la
imagen de debajo t
y esto
esto tienes pues la transformación que
era una transformación lineal eso es muy
importante en todo esto así que esto es
lo mismo que aplicarle la transformación
a la suma de a conté pero qué sucede
qué sucede pues esto de aquí está entre
lo que está adentro porque ahí ve eran
elementos del sub espacio y si son
elementos del sub espacio su suma es un
elemento del sub espacio así que esto
pertenece a la imagen
dv
perfecto ahora qué pasa si me tomo un
escalarse y consideró una escalar sé por
qué
a dónde es un vector en b entonces quién
es esto pues de nuevo la transformación
es lineal y como la transformación en
link es lineal esto es lo mismo que la
transformación del escalarse por el
vector
ahora bien de nuevo esto aquí lo que
está dentro de la te lo que le estoy
aplicando la transformación pertenece a
ve de nuevo por el axioma de cerradura
bajo la multiplicación para el sub
espacio ve yo ya sé que ve es un sub
espacio así que esto también pertenece a
la imagen debe muy bien y por último por
último tengo que checar que el vector 0
el lector 0 este en la imagen debe pero
el vector 0 si le aplicó la
transformación al vector 0 como es
lineal como la transformación es lineal
el vector 0 siempre es la imagen del
vector 0 así que esto de nuevo
del mismo color
esto de nuevo
está en la imagen debe y bien como se
checan estas tres condiciones entonces
la imagen del psuv espacio de bajo la
transformación de la imagen debe bajo t
sube espacio
su despacio pero ya no del dominio ya no
de rn sino de r m
la imagen de de bajo t es un sub espacio
de r m
bueno pues una pregunta natural que nos
puede surgir después de haber hecho todo
esto es que sucede qué sucede si
considero a todo r n qué pasa si me fijo
en la imagen de todo el dominio pues
habíamos estado llamando a esto esto
sería la imagen
la imagen de r n
rm bajo
hasta ahora sólo habíamos estado
considerando subconjuntos o sub espacios
propios pero ahora quiero considerar a
todo el dominio como él
el objeto al que le voy a aplicar la
transformación así que quiero fijarme en
la imagen de rn bajo como un conjunto
como un conjunto esto quiere después son
todos los vectores en rm que son de la
forma tv x
que está en el condominio
r m recuerden la transformación va de rm
donde x pertenece al dominio a r n
esto es lo que quiero considerar y bueno
yo sé que si es fino una transformación
te lleva de rm a rm entonces esto de
aquí y esto se llama el dominio
dominio y esto se llama el co dominio
como dominio
y podrían pensar podrían irse con la
cinta de que la imagen de rm bajo la
transformación que es todo el condominio
pero ese no es el caso de hecho una
terminología que no es tan común en
álgebra lineal pero que podría ayudar a
clarificar esto es que muchas veces esto
se llama el rango
el rango de la transformación d
es decir son sólo aquellos elementos en
el dominio son aquellos elementos de rm
que provienen de elementos en rn
y bueno esto normalmente
a esto se le llama la imagen
la imagen
esto estoy aquí es la imagen de ti y
normalmente se denota como
en la imagen dt y no se vayan a
confundir antes hablaba de la imagen de
subconjuntos bajo la transformación t en
el momento en el que mi subconjunto es
todo el dominio simplemente hablo de la
imagen de t no quiero hablar de la
imagen del dominio bajo t es lo mismo
que simplemente decir la imagen de t
déjenme trato de ilustrar este concepto
supongan sé que esto de aquí estoy aquí
es mi condominio decir esto aquí acr n
perdón de rm
y que estoy acá
estoy acá es rn esto es mi dominio
entonces la imagen si le aplicó la
transformación a todos los elementos a
todos los vectores de mi dominio lo que
obtengo es una especie de copia bueno
quería que estos dos casos aparecieran
una especie de copia
bajo la transformación te te manda a
cada elemento a ti algún elemento acá
pero pueden existir elementos en el co
dominio que no sean parte de la imagen
por ejemplo aquí puede estar algún
vector raro al que no le pegue pero eso
no le quita es así es importante la
imagen de t siempre es un sub espacio de
dominio lo que no puedo garantizar es
que sea todo el condominio bien entonces
esto sería la imagen de la
transformación t y bueno sólo una
aclaración cuando dije que esto era una
copia no me refería a una copia
fidedigna simplemente es como la imagen
no vayan a creer por ejemplo la
transformación te podría mandar a todo
rn al vector 0 y eso es una
transformación lineal y claramente el
vector 0 no es lo mismo que por ejemplo
r 5 así que bueno aclarado eso vamos a
ver quién es exactamente la imagen de
una transformación t
bien pues es un hecho es un hecho que
toda transformación de rm a rm se puede
expresar en la forma de x es igual a una
matriz a por el vector x donde haga es
una matriz de emed por n y bien entonces
si si escribo esto de ese modo quien es
quien es la imagen imagen de r n bajo t
déjenme lo escribo de varios modos por
un lado esto es lo mismo esto es lo
mismo lo denota vamos por tdn y bien
como decía arriba esto es esto de aquí
tvr m
y es lo mismo que la imagen
la imagen de ti
como estoy tomando todo el dominio sólo
tengo que decir la imagen de t que
dijimos que se notaba como
imagen de ti pero por lo que tengo acá
arriba
este conjunto sencillamente es como te
dé x es lo mismo que la matriz a por el
vector x el conjunto de los vectores de
la forma a por x que son vectores en el
dominio nrm donde x pertenece a r n
muy bien y para averiguar quién es este
conjunto de aquí lo que voy a hacer es
escribir a mi matriz a como la matriz de
m&m que tiene por columnas a los
vectores a1 a2 hasta
en esos son mis vectores columna de la
matriz a y la voy a multiplicar por un
miembro de rm genérico es decir por una
lista x 1 x 2 hasta x m de números
reales arbitrarios que me da este
producto matriz vector pues me da x 1
por el vector a 1 + x 2 por el vector a
2 más hasta voy sumando todos hasta x n
por a n
pero como x 1 x 2 x 3 todos hasta x n
pueden tomar cualquier valor real en
realidad lo que estoy diciendo es que
este conjunto de aquí es en realidad
igual al
el espacio
espacio de columnas
de la matriz a que habíamos denotado por
si en algún momento
bien esto es un resultado muy bonito
porque me dice que si quiero encontrar
la imagen de una transformación lineal t
es decir lo que resulta si le aplicó la
transformación a todos los elementos del
dominio lo que termina siendo la imagen
de todo el dominio bajo la
transformación t entonces lo único que
tengo que hacer o más bien eso es igual
a el espacio de columnas de alguna
matriz que representa a mi
transformación lineal t es esto de aquí
precisamente las combinaciones lineales
todas absolutamente todas las
combinaciones lineales de los vectores
columna de mi matriz estoy aquí es el
sub espacio vectorial generado por los
vectores columna x a1 a2 hasta hasta a m
y por supuesto esto es un subconjunto es
un sub espacio vectorial de r
pero en realidad este resultado es muy
bonito y lo vamos a usar mucho en el
futuro